質問があるならば よろしいですか
すいません  うん  あの 私の今の職場には
あの 会社の因果法則はすごいよく知ってる人たちがいて
で 私も入社してそんなに経たないんで
結構あれやれこれやれって言われて
まあそれは別に ああなるほどと思ってるんですけども
その人たちがやっぱり実生活では
私生活では あの ギャンブルとか酒が大好きなんですけど
でもそういう人たちでも
何か仕事上っていうことで割り切って
仕事上の賢者ということでいいんでしょうか
うんうん まあそうするしかないでしょ
それははっきり割り切った方がいい
あなた方のやった人は仕事上は聞きますよと
それ終わったらどうったことはないんだよと
口を挟むなよと 仕事上はまあ腕がいいんだから経験があるんだから
まあそれ言う必要はないんですけど
そういう風に割り切って割り切った方がいいんです
やっぱりものを学んでもらう場合は
その学ぶ項目によってその人は上なんですからね
すべて教えてくれる人っていうのは俗世間でいませんからね
だから あの 時々 この中年の人とかね
運転免許を取ろうとかね
教習所に行ったら教えてくれる若者なんですね
しょうがないんですよ
あの 退職した男性たちも
また何か仕事をしたいと思ってコンビニに仕事に行くでしょ
コンビニの店長が三十五歳と三十二歳とか
それでバイトに行った人が六十歳なんですよ
それでトラブっちゃうんですよ
この若者たちは トラブる必要ないんですよ
自分がもうびっしびし仕事したかもしれませんよ
もうもう今もう定年退職している当時では偉かったかもしれません
だけど今収入がないし
もうちょっと仕事をしたいし
体力もあるし だったらまあバイトにもうコンビニに行ったんだから
もう荷物運びやら何でもかんでも言う通りにやるしかないんです
そのセクションにおいては
あの人が目上なんです
それがわからないならばね
もう話にならないんですよ
だからもう関係くじけちゃいますよ
あの 決して若い人はね
年寄りをバカにしませんよ
ちゃんと言う通りにやると
本当にあの年なのに真面目に仕事しているんだと
言って仕事終わった途端逆になっちゃうんですよ
いろいろアドバイスを受けたりもしますよ
仕事は終わってからは
でも何かこれこれちょっと整理は間違ってるでしょ
それはダメですよって言ったら
あんた何やという顔で見ると
あのじじいがね 迷惑やと
頑固でもう気持ち悪いと
できればクビにしたいなと
明日から来なきゃ方がいい
来ない方がいいんじゃないかと思っちゃいます
だからそんなもうもう場が違うというかね
まあそれはよくやるんだからね
だからいつでもこの条件の中で物事成り立すんであって
コンビニの中は二十四時間コンビニじゃないんだからね
その場が違ったら全部関係も違うでしょうしね
だからこのずっと同じ関係を持ってほしいと思っちゃうと結構トラブります
踊りの勉強を稽古をしようかなと思ったところで
若者の連中がまあ一生懸命踊りを教えてくれるかも
それで私が先生殿とか先生先生と呼ばれているでしょうし
だからって ずっと自分がどこでも先生と呼ばれてほしいと思っちゃうと
これがまずいんですよ
紹介する時でも まあ年下の人かもしれません
だけどこの これは本当は私の踊りの先生ですと
それ踊りの先生で人生の先生じゃないんです
そういうことで 人間っていうのは何か一つ二つはできる
それを学んでもらいたければ
まあその場合はその人は目上なんですね
そういう風にちゃんと割り切ることなんです
はい 他のお質問はございますか？ 先生
はい  あの やっぱり自分の人から批判されたり
叱られたりするのがすごく苦手な人間で
自分は成長しなきゃいけないと思うんですけれども
やっぱり人から叱られたり批判されたりすると
こう すぐくじけてしまうんですけれども
それは自分で直すしかないというか
どういうふうにしたらよろしいでしょうか
それ自分で直さなきゃ
どうすることもできない
我々には 助けてくれませんよ
あげません くじけてしまうということは成長しないということだからね
成長したいと思ったことは本気なのかというね
疑問になりますからね
成長する人はこう思いますよ
すべての人は森羅万象が自分に教えてくれるんだと
すべてが自分の師匠であると思いますよ
だから頭の人っていうのはね
まあ子育てしながらね
まあ結局は私が育ててもらっているか
私が育てるか はっきりわかりませんよと
いう場合あるでしょうね
子供に育てられているか
もう正しくそういうことなんですよ
自分が子供育てるわけじゃない
結局は子供に育てられてる場合もあります
そういうわけで 世の中のすべてのものは森羅万象が我々には
それは禅の世界ではごく一般的な言葉なんですよ
森羅万象が仏法を語っているんだと
で アホだから聞こえないんだ
この学ぶ学ぶっていうこと
どういうことかというと
この会社で学ぶっていうことは学びじゃないんです
仏教でいう学ぶっていうことは
自分 人格が変わることなんです
ある日 北千住の駅で七時
朝七時ぐらいかな六時半ぐらいかな
私はもう大阪に行こうかなと
行ったところで冬でね
まあ国は優しかったんだからね
あちこちホームレスがいたんです
今はもうホームレスいさせませんからね
いることはいるんですけど
まあ追い出しますからね
北千住の駅の前で その時
駅はすごく古くて できたなことでね
今はもうびっくりする
見違えるほど発展してまして
あの場所も何もないんです
で 歩いていくと あのちょっとした壊れたベンチが
そちらホームレスの人が
まあ寒い時でしたけどね
座っていて まあ酒飲んでるんですね
人は誰もいない 私はささっとそこら辺はもう通っていくと
この人はせめて私にすぐ話しかけたんです
あの辺ではだいたいまあ普通話しかけます
だから私も誰が喋ってきたって
何のことなくどうっていう感じで話やったりはする
すごい人間としてはなんかよく優しいというかね
人間できてます 今発展しているんだから
もう亡くなってるでしょうね
うん じゃあ私もそこももうすぐもう忙しかったしね
もうもう電車ギリギリにして行くんだからね
止まってごちゃごちゃあっち見たりこっち見たりする暇がないんです
私には うん 始まったら私はもう話したら
なんのことなく一緒にどうそう
だからそこでその人は本当は私に何か教えてるんですよ
別に酒勧めてるという感じでおっとあかん
私はその瞬間で で 普段だったらそんなこと言ったら私は何するのかと
この人がまあホームレスですけど
もう私に対してすごい平等で見て一緒に二人で酒でも飲もうかという
朝ものすごい朝早いのに
だからそんなことは外人ぐらいでしょと思ったでしょうかね
で 私は何のことなく すごく丁寧にお礼をして
もう本当ものすごく忙しいんだと
今電車に間に合わないんだと
二本しかないんだから 「
あ そうか」 それで話が終了
だからそこで で 私は何か学んでるんですけど
で 学ぶというそういうことなんです
ある日 京都かどこかで駅で待ってると
あのばあちゃんがね あんパン食べて食べてるんです
しゃべったらそこで半分はい
で その出来事で私は何か学ばなくちゃいけないんです
そういう場合 私は決してその人に失礼な態度を取りませんよ
そういう だからそういう瞬間でも学ぶことがあるんです
そういうことで この自分の人格に対して
性格に対して改良することが学びなんです
要するに 仕事の中身を教えてくれるということは
まあそれは風俗世間の知識であって
学びということになりません
本当のところは ですから
この学ぶ場合は 親鸞晩鐘がちゃんと道を教えているんです
誰から学ぶということはもう決まってない
誰でもいい もうちゃんと育つ人であるならば
別に誰でもいいんです
育てない人が口げたたり
腹が立ったり 喧嘩したりっていろいろあります
育つ人なら瞬間でわかるんです
これやだ  そういうことで
自分でそこは何とかしなくちゃいけない
あくまでもね 自分の心が変わらないように何か学ぶではないかということをね
性格としては思わないと
他人にはどうすることができないのです
はい 次の質問は  はい よろしいでしょうか
よく三法印のことは一切開くを外して涅槃寂静っていう風に書いてある本があったりするんですけれども
あれは大乗仏教的な解釈なんでしょうか
諸法無我と諸行無常と
そして涅槃寂静って感じで三法印って書いてる本もあったんですけど
うーん 三宝印経がね 空と無我と無常なんですけどね
まあ四つにしてますね
涅槃寂静というね 別に一箇所でパーリ語でないんですけど
涅槃寂静ということは当然あります
まああれもう派手に使うのは大乗の方ですけど
間違ってるわけじゃないんです
ただ 経典を読んでもそういうふうに四つ並んではないんです
はい では  えっと 自分の性格とかを少しずつ変えていくっていう風に思ってたんですけれども
なんかそれじゃなんか嫌だって
ちょっと気持ちが落ち込んだ時に
そうじゃなくて えっと
仏教を勉強してたらガラッと変わるんじゃないかと思って元気になったことがあるんですけど
その そんなこと考えても
うーん 考えることに私には管理できるんですけどね
少しずつ変わるっていうのは
今自分があって それが少しずつ変わっていくっていうのは
ちょっと  まあこれ言葉の問題でしょうね
少しずつとどこまででしょうかとね
仏教が言うのはこのグラジュアリー
いわゆるプログレッシブに
徐々に順番で変わるということとやっていくのは少しずつという
まあね この量の問題だったら
少しっていうのはちょっと困るんですけどね
あまりにも量が少しでもう何百年もかかるならばね
ちょっと問題でではなくて
この順番に徐々に変わっていくというね
の方が正しいんです ガラッといきなり変わるということはないんです
それを期待するのは間違い
え？ それを期待してはいない
それは変わりたくないんだからね
そこまで怠けていて 当然変えてくれるでしょうという考え方なんですね
で ちゃんと順番で段取り通りに変わっていくというね
グラジュアルプログレスということで
ということで マイナープログレスではないんです
すごく微妙に変わっていくんだ
これ微妙に変わっていく
どこを通るんでいつ終わるのかというね
こともあります だから早く変わりたいというならばね
そこは別に早く変わりたいと思っていると
早く変わりたいと思ったっても
やっぱり性格は順番で変わるんですよ
それだからね 因果法則的なものだから
ある日突然っていうのはちょっと考えない方がいいんです
あの時々すごいショックなこととか起きると
戻るような  ん？ あの  徐々に進んでいるような気がいたの
踏み込んでいたのが戻るような気がして
時々落ち込んだりするんですけど
そういうのは  これ通訳ないとわからないです
質問は  そういうのは  なんて言ってます？ それはそれで観察するんですか？ 徐々に進んでいってるような
先生がさっきおっしゃったみたいに
徐々に進んでいくんですっておっしゃったんですけども
徐々に進んでいるような気がするんですけども
なんか心のショックみたいな入ったら
それがガクッと下がってしまうようなことがあるんですけども
それは  何か管理の仕方ありますか？できたら戻ったら
通訳ないからやっぱりわからない
[笑い] ですから その心が成長している先生が少しずつ成長していくんですとおっしゃってるんですけど
何かのショックで戻ってしまう状況もあるんですけど
それはどういうふうに管理したらよろしいんでしょうか？と
それは それはあくまでも本人の問題でしょ
それは他人にはどうすることもできない
徐々に成長しているんですけど
ショック来ちゃってまた元に戻ったというならばね
話にならんですけどね
それだったらなんでこうなったのか
徐々に成長しているんだぞとかね
そういう気がするんだけど
だったらいいなっていう希望も含めて思っているだけなんですけど
なんか上がってるのかっていう
時々  単純だ [笑い] 別にその上がってるような気分がしてるだけの
冷静に分析して上がってる下がってるではなくて
その上がってる下がってるっていう評価自体もその自分の気分だけによって生じてるものなんですけどもっていうことです
まあ謙虚でないっていうことははっきり見えますからね
成長する場合必要ということは謙虚っていうことだからね
親鸞晩鐘が指導者で教えてくれてる人はもう極限に謙虚でしょ
ああ ちょっと成長したんだなと本人が思ったらね
これが成長とは計算できませんね
私の場合 他の方よりあの出発地点が低いので
成長とはなりならないと思いますけど
ま 私にはそんな大胆なことは言えませんだからね
自分のことをそんなにも高く思っているならばね
もうちょっと助けることは不可能ですけどね
他の人のことよく分かったんですね
あんたは 私も分かってないんだよ
他の何考えてる人とか
やっぱりそんな能力ないんですけど
あなたによくありますね
他人のことまでよく理解しているという
だからいかに傲慢かということですよ
それに気づかないんです
私たちはそうやって区別差別なし
物事を見ていますけど
人は何やって 人は何やってるかっていうことを明らかにインチキ成長なんです
それから そういう人々はいつでも周りの人々のことを見ながら自分をいろいろ合わせますからね
それ成長じゃないですね
瞑想の場合は一番悪いやり方であって
やってはいけない禁止なものをやってみんなやってますから
私はあんまり まあそれで楽ですからね
私は真剣になれなくていいやと
ああ 今日のポイントは全然わからないでしょうね
おそらく 親鸞晩鐘が教えてくれるという禅の教えですからね
親鸞晩鐘がブッダであって
生の声で語っていると
で 美しく文学的に言ってますけど
本当のことを言ってます
我々には何かなる何からでも学べるんです
その態度に心がなるっていうことは
あの人とは違います 私はという話じゃないんです
よく言うことそれが 自分がすごく惨めなつもりなんですけど
これ惨めじゃないんです
その人の言葉で判断しているんだからできることでもないし
近寄りがたいほどのこれ傲慢と呼ぶんです
だから これ慢というのはね
まあ竹とかそういう木に例えていますから
これあんまりにも伸びると伸びると伸びると結局下りて地面に触れますからね
だからすごい謙虚でいる
地面に触れてますから
謙虚わけじゃなくて ありすぎ
伸びすぎ だから高慢 ちょこちょこっと高慢だったらえらい態度でかいんですよ
それならそこそこ高慢な人というのはすごい態度でっかくて
人と喧嘩してあんた何やとか言ったりとかね
もうあんまりにも高慢な人っていうのは
ものすごいみんなと違って
私はもうという風に地面に触れてます
だから本人も他人もすごい謙虚な人やと勘違いするんですが
違います 伸びすぎ 伸びすぎて曲がっているんです
そう思うと他人から学べないしね
例えばね 突然何か言われてショックを受けるってことはありえないでしょ
成長する場合は 他人に何か言われたらそれがチャンスでしょうに
その時はそれでショックを受けたから
それがなかなか消えなかったので
それで自我があるからそれが長く続くんだっていうところで
その時は自我の観察をしてたんですけど
それですごくやってみたかったんですけれど
ただ その自我があるからこういう苦しいんだって思ってもなかなか消えなくて
それでその  もうそれで試行錯誤で頑張るしかないんですけどね
自分の傲慢で計画するようには人は成長しません
成長には成長のプロセスがありますからね
自我がどこにも生じません
自分の成長のプログラムということは
人は仕込みません 込めないんです
成長してない人はどうやって成長のプログラムを込めますかね
物事は自我がないんですから
自分が思う通りに成長することではありません
物事は物事だから 因果法則によって成り立つのものだから
成長と言葉使うと成長にも成長の因果法則があって
プロセスがあるんですから
そのプロセスに沿って成長するんであって
ああなりたい こうなりたいと言ったって
なるわけでもないんです
大体世界っていうのは
環境っていうのはすばりと一番痛いところに行ってくれます
そこは直せるところなんですね
そこで落ち込むということは
チャンスを逃したということなんです
大体聞きたくはないものでしょ
落ち込んだり がっかりしたりするのは
聞きたくはないところ
自分が明らかに隠したいところなんですね
それ言ってくれるんだから
それがプロセスなんです
いろいろ隠しておいて
ああ 立派に成長しましたと言い張りたいのかもしれませんだけどね
死んだ番犬はそれ隠しておけません
それは先に言うんです
成長する前に正直にならなくちゃいけないんです
素直になるということは
自我がすごくもう機能しなくなるんですね
それからのは成長はそんなに難しいことではなくて
すごく淡々と来ます 誰でも何か言われたら
がっかりするのは この隠しておきたいところにもう狙い撃ちで言われるんだからなんです
しかし 言ってる相手はそんなことわかりませんしね
普通ごく普通なことを言ってるのに
相手がひどく傷ついちゃって落ち込んでいるというならばね
それはあくまでも言われた側の問題であって
えっと 死後錯誤で頑張るしかないんです
逆に正しく取る人は落ち込んだことも
あ これ何やと またそこは勉強にするんですね
こういうことで落ち込んだと
[終始背景音楽]